tonight is the beginning of the Jewish
holiday of Rosh Hashanah when all Jewish
people need to be home before sundown
yes which is why I didn't have anyone to
write a punchline for this joke
nobody won does one guy get ready first
we have routers Catholic wrote the rest
get ready for some Catholic comedy yeah
oh so this can of Guinness is rolling
down the street what's really going on
President Obama
you've all heard there's a huge
everyone's talking about it today like
it's a scandal
yeah it's absurd President Obama is
being criticized for saluting a soldier
while reportedly holding a pumpkin spice
latte yeah
today Obama sincerely apologized while
eating a maple glazed doughnut very
sorry
sorry about that they're mad at him it's
ridiculous yeah I love it
the Secret Service is now considering
several new measures to keep people from
trying to get into the White House yeah
the first thing they're going to do to
keep people out is put up a sign that
says Blockbuster Video save money on
pencils yeah this is interesting in an
interview that he just gave Bill Clinton
said one of the things on his bucket
list is riding a horse in Mongolia yeah
he said it in the October issue of if
you know what I mean
[Applause]
[Music]
I I love I love if you know it at any
magazine in that case I don't know what
he means
okay the federal prison population has
dropped by almost 5,000 people good news
it's expected to go back up once the NFL
season ends
[Applause]
Oh an evangelical Christian listen to
this an evangelical Christian rewrote
Harry Potter so that all the witchcraft
is removed yeah and guess what kids just
love it you can read the whole series
all seven books in five minutes now that
boring witchcraft yeah that's just crazy
to me I know it's about an orphan that
gets out of school it's about an orphan
who's homeschooled yeah that's a lot of
map yeah and nothing happens
this is weird I'm not making this up a
video has surfaced of a brawl among a
group of Where's Waldo impersonators yes
bunch of Where's Waldo impersonators got
into a big fight yeah now they're on the
run
police can't find them
[Music]
in a new interview she just gave a new
interview in a new interview Kim
Cattrall said there could be another Sex
in the City movie yeah an hour later
Isis surrendered only so much they can
take fascinating from the world of
science using spinal electrodes
researchers have found a way for women
to achieve orgasm with the push of a
button yes unfortunately very few men
can find the button
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I do and I it doesn't work
out I do that
you